dire une chose je remercie les
collectivités les aires les préfets
évidemment les soignants les agents des
collectivités qui permettent hier sur la
seule journée de faire plus de 650000
injection de rappel dans notre pays
c'est un record est-ce qu'il va
continuer à monter ce qui t'a européen
comme le dit Premier ministre qui va
continuer à monter qui montre un qui a
l'engouement pour le rappel de que de la
logistique suis et que nous sommes
capable de répondre et 3 que nous sommes
dans une course contre la montre pas ça
fait 5e vague et qu'il faut aller vite
donc ne m'entendrais jamais me plaindre
du fait qu'il y a beaucoup de Français
qui souhaite se faire vacciner vous
interroger madame la sénatrice sur le
vaccin moderna et pardon je ne peux pas
laisser dire excusez-moi de dire
n'importe quoi ce n'est pas responsable
de dire cela le vaccin modern est un
vaccin ARN messager qui fonctionne aussi
bien que le vaccin Fighter c'est pas
parce que vous avez une première et
deuxième dose de fizer que vous ne devez
pas avoir une dose de Modern Art trop de
ma session moi mais madame la sénatrice
j'ai eu de l'Astra du fizer du moderna
je me présente devant vous il n'y a pas
pénurie de vaccins le d'avant
nous avons nous avons nous avons
suffisamment de vaccin pour protéger
toute la population qui compte c'est un
vaccin ARN messager qui soit du n'y a
aucune pénurie nous avons envoyé cette
semaine 4 million de dos complémentaire
à la médecine de ville qui vient de
commander encore plusieurs millions de
dos je le redis pour les moins de 30 ans
c'est le fizer pour pour tous les plus
de 30 ans et homo Bernard
indistinctement il y a du fizer madame
la sénatrice ce n'est pas vrai ce que
vous dites ce n'est pas vrai il y a des
erreurs dans les centres de vaccination
nous avons des millions de dos qui sont
en cours d'utilisation et merci
d'encourager un peu ce qui vaccine au
lieu de hurler madame la sénatrice
[Musique]